it is June 29 2023 and you are watching
the code report fake it till you make it
not only does this principle apply to
getting a software engineering job but
it's also a great way to build a billion
dollar startup case in point IRL a
social media unicorn that raised over
200 million dollars from VCS like
softbank's Vision Fund in 2021 it
exploded to 20 million users with 12
million monthly active users and it
looked like it was going to become the
app to connect gen Z people to events in
real life there was just one small
problem 95 of its users were fake you
were just making it look like you were
playing you're a phony and as of
yesterday it's been permanently shut
down not even a giant pile of money to
burn through could save it the company
was founded by a Visionary leader
Abraham Shafi who was once praised by
Forbes just like other Visionary leaders
like Sam bankman freed and Elizabeth
Holmes but back in April the IRL board
suspended him for misconduct because
apparently it's illegal to mislead
investors by creating fake users and the
SEC has launched an investigation and if
any rich people lost money they'll
definitely bring him to justice so
probably problem with venture capital is
that when you take the money you either
grow or die there isn't much Middle
Ground especially for an app without
Revenue if your app isn't growing but
you still want to be rich you need to
learn about growth hacking what you do
is create a for Loop that runs 20
million times ideally in JavaScript and
then for each iteration in that Loop you
create a new user record in the database
with a fake name and Anime profile image
you then present this database on your
pitch deck and then a few days later you
should get a check from Silicon Valley
Bank for millions of dollars you'll want
to take that money and hire a bunch of
product managers that do absolutely
nothing for three hundred thousand
dollars a year while funneling some of
this money to Offshore accounts and
untrackable cryptos eventually you will
get caught and go to jail but you should
only have to do a few years in a white
collar prison camp which is more like a
vacation resort when you get out you'll
be rich and you can repeat the cycle in
reality though the most difficult
objective for any app developer is not
the software development itself but
building up an actual user base writing
code and allocating money for a business
is actually not as hard as you think
like imagine you had 10 million dollars
and 10 software Engineers right now how
would you turn those resources into an
actual business that attracts a loyal
user base in all likelihood you would
fail as most startups do and that's why
fake engagement on the Internet is a
huge business and now it's easier than
ever with artificial intelligence like
there's this Twitter clone called
chirpur that's entirely inhabited by Ai
and there's still a thriving Black
Market where people buy things like
Facebook likes and Amazon reviews that
are often run by real humans in these
engagement Farms where one person could
easily pretend to be a hundred people
IRL is not the only company out there
inflating its numbers you've also got
Aussie that was claiming 50 million
users when the truth was likely less
than 1 million you've also got another
Forbes 30 under 30 who stole 175 million
dollars from JP Morgan by inflating its
user base and even big public companies
like block have been accused of
overstating numbers with fake and
duplicate accounts and people have long
suspected that apps like Facebook and
Tick Tock fake their engagement but we
don't have enough evidence to prove it
yet and of course there's the dead
internet Theory where some people
speculate that almost all of the content
on the Internet is bought activity and
automatically generated by AI like
there's no way 2 million real humans
subscribe to my channel I think the real
number is more like 12 which is still
impressive considering I'm not a real
human myself but I'm just gonna fake it
until I make it this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one
[Music]